c'est aujourd'hui 21 mars la journée
mondiale de la poésie notre phrase du
jour elle est signée forcément un
d'impôt est chrétien de troyes un poète
du 12e siècle le corps s'en va le coeur
séjournent
et pourquoi cette citation tout
simplement car c'est l'épitaphe et qui
figure sur la tombe d'andrée chedid
andrée chedid poète également disparu en
2011 dont il est question pour la suite
de ce set 8 avec valérie jose bonsoir et
chef de choeur directrice de l'ensemble
vocal de saint quentin en yvelines et
philippe raynaud bonsoir à vous je sept
compositeurs pour également l'ensemble
vocal de saint quentin et vous préparé
ce spectacle hommage à andrée chedid qui
s'intitule au coeur du coeur justement
vos choristes qui vont s'approprier les
textes de l'auteur c'est bien ça
exactement pour une soirée qui rend
hommage à andrée chedid qui est morte un
20 mars c'est à dire juste la veille de
la journée mondiale de la poésie c'est
un signe cette femme était
exceptionnelle et on pensait depuis
longtemps lui rendre hommage puisque le
lien entre ces poésie et la musique qui
peut en tirer est merveilleux car
comment vous avez travaillé justement
pour mettre en musique tout ce travail
comment vous avez travaillé avec les
différents compositeurs de l'ensemble de
50 et vient bien évidemment que il y
avait déjà des pièces qui était écrite
autour de six poèmes dont celle de
philippe raynaud que je connaissais donc
bien évidemment le rapport était simple
à faire et j'ai demandé à philippe si
bien évidemment dans cette programmation
on pouvait faire de ces pièces est
chantée de ces pièces mais comment on
met en musique justement tous eu tous
ces textes qui existent de d'andrée
chedid comment vous avez travaillé
personnellement j'ai eu la chance de
travailler avec elle c
andré-jean c'est connu en 1999 je crois
et
bon certes n comment dire complicité
immédiate dans le dans l'attachement à
l'art avec des choses qu'on connait
c'est ensemble qu'on avait bien et puis
de là est venue l'idée de ne travailler
ensemble elle avait l'habitude de dire
qu'elle ne connaissait absolument pas la
musique
je peux vous dire que c'est complètement
faux il y a qu'à lire ses poèmes
d'ailleurs c'est déjà c'est déjà une
musique des mots au delà de d'une
musique qui caresse l'âme avec tout le
le sens voire lès sens qu'elle met dans
un an dans un poème ses poèmes sont
souvent très très court une difficulté
est aussi une chance c'est l'absence
totale de ponctuation danser dans ses
poèmes ce qui veut dire que on s'arrête
où on repart ou en sachant que un mot
charnière entre deux passages peut aussi
être une fin un début ou bien un double
sens pas vous dire que c'est difficile
de mettre les textes d'andrée en musique
mais en tout cas c'est un c'est un
travail passionnant et un travail
passionnant parce qu'on travaille sur un
matériau qui est absolument unique au
départ
le spectacle qui se déroulera à
guyancourt sur le site de la batterie la
salle de spectacle à l'auditorium école
c'est un hommage qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre du printemps des poètes de la
biennale de la poésie d'ailleurs on a vu
quelques images
andrée chedid était venu un circuit en
cours à saint quentin en yvelines à
l'occasion de la biennale à la maison de
la poésie à l'invitation de son
directeur on a vu que justement ces
images-là de sa présence à ce moment là
le but en mettant aussi en musique c'est
de souligner la modernité du texte c'est
de faire ça cette rencontre entre
quelque chose de plus contemporain et
des textes de poésie
je sais pas si ça sera peut être
prétentieux de ma part de dire que
j'ajoute de la modernité au texte de
d'andré va travailler avec beaucoup de
modestie sur ces textes mais vous aviez
tout de même une volonté d'artistes de
composites et oui tout à fait
c'est vrai qu'avant d'écrire une note on
se pose pas mal de questions moi notre
monde mais
mais c'est vrai qu'elle avait aussi
l'art de l'étang des choses mais vas-y
exprime toi c'est bon c'est vrai qu'elle
connaissait ma musique je connaissais
ses textes et et c'est vrai que c'est un
des souvenirs merveilleux d'avoir
d'avoir travaillé avec elle ajouté la
modernité vraiment je ne sais pas en
tout cas j'en ai pas la prétention mais
peut-être permettre simplement à des
artistes qui s'intéressent peut-être un
public qui s'intéresse peut-être d'abord
à la musique d'aller vers autre chose de
deux mails et les ah ça je crois que
c'est une chance et il n'y a pas un
risque aussi de peut-être de trahir le
matériau de départ aussi c'était pas un
risque alors que lorsque vous vous êtes
dit on va travailler sur ce projet c'est
toujours le risque mais ça vaut le coup
de faire du challenge comme ça et au
niveau des choristes de l'ensemble vocal
de saint quentin à que je remercie parce
que ce programme est pas évident puisque
bien évidemment quand on écoute du
mozart on s'attend à ce que ça soit du
mozart et on a des repères là il faut
découvrir chaque parole du compositeur
chaque parole aussi de l'auteur andrée
chedid en effet est une femme qui
maniait la langue française d'une façon
merveilleuse mais qui n'est pas si aisé
à comprendre à rentrer de l'intérieur or
notre intériorité nous deux choristes à
chaque fois est remise en cause et on se
pose des questions et qu'est ce qu'on va
interpréter comment va-t-on
l'interpréter est-ce qu'on ne travaille
pas le compositeur qui est en face en
plus et qui vient très régulièrement nos
répétitions en face et le stress c'est
un travail très difficile on va écouter
andrée chedid justement je vous le
disais elle est venue à guyancourt c'est
en 2005 elle était venu lire quelques
textes elle évoqué aussi la nécessité de
désacraliser aussi la poésie cette
poésie ses poèmes qui font parfois un
peu peur au public
je fonce vers l'horizon qui s'écartent
je m'empare du tour qui le fuit j'épouse
mais visage d'enfance
j'adopte des cordes aujourd'hui je me g
dans des turbulences je pénètre désobéi
je suis multiple je ne suis personne la
poésie on l'a toujours par de la poésie
en attendons toujours une espèce de
crainte de la poésie mais je trouve je
crois que la m comme ça au niveau des
personnes c'est active en est
et et dynamisant j'ai demandé aussi à
nos invités si la poésie fait un peu
peur parce que les poèmes ça fait peur
aussi au public comme le dit andrée
chedid alors justement vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble vocal de saint quentin ce
nous faisons un gros travail sur les
poésies forcément c'est notre base c'est
notre et on s'est rendu compte que la
transmission orale c'est à dire celle
qu'on transmet grâce au coeur qu'on naît
et puis grâce au coeur qu'on y met c'est
un moyen très efficace pour faire
rentrer les jeunes dans la poésie c'est
à dire que bien souvent après les
concerts il ya un d'un en fait mais je
vais aller lire alors que la démarche de
rentrer dans un bouquin c'est quand même
plus difficile souvent donc là il ya le
support orale le support du spectacle
c'est très sympa andrée chedid pour vous
ça représente quoi justement vous
entendu tout à l'heure ce témoignage
puisque vous vous l'aviez rencontrez
vous l'aviez rencontre et peut-être pas
du tout je n'ai pas eu cette chance là
par contre je connais son mari et je
pense que c'est un monsieur qui est
tellement qui émane de lui tellement de
bonnes choses que sa femme devait être
une femme aussi merveilleuse que lui le
spectacle se déroule mardi pour ceux qui
hésiteraient peut-être qu'il aurait
quand même encore quelques quelques
réticences et qui auraient peur de ce
travail de de poésie ou l'ordi terrier
quoi comment vous présenteriez ce
spectacle qu'ils vont découvrir le thème
étant au coeur du coeur le choeur sera
beaucoup traité je pense que vis-à-vis
des sentiments que de chaque être humain
possède dans son coeur et bien ce sera
un bon moment pour les petits comme pour
les grands
la même chose pour vous oui eux aussi un
mot venez parce que le travail qu'a fait
le l'ensemble vocal est vraiment
formidable j'ai eu la chance de le
suivre depuis quelques semaines quelques
mois est vraiment vous allez vous
régaler vous n'avez pas été trop dur
avec eux c'est pas moi de répondre
allez-y on vous a le face à face
maintenant je me dis ce fait on dont
vous êtes installés hors antenne vous
êtes face à face prouver débat de
travail s'est bien passé de toute façon
dans l'ensemble vocal on aime l'exigence
donc on aime bien être avec des gens
exigeants vous restez avec nous on va
continuer à parler de vos différents
spectacles parce que vous travaillez
aussi pour un autre spectacle qui se
jouera le 6 avril le mot de la fin juste
autour de d'andrée chedid pour jacques
fournier le directeur de la maison de la
poésie il était avec nous la semaine
dernière pour parler du printemps des
poètes voilà ce qu'il disait à propos
d'andrée chedid andrée chedid était la
grand mère de m la main
louis chedid elle était passionnée par
la chanson aussi puisqu'elle avait écrit
des textes pour son petit fils et voilà
on a tenu à accompagner cet hommage
parce qu andré chedid est une dame qui a
lancé la première biennale de la poésie
en 2003 elle avait accepté l'invitation
et voilà on c'est une d'un petit on n'a
qu'à jean j'ai toujours énormément de
respect